hey guys thanks for being here my name
is Lee Bratch I'm the president of Texas
blockchain council I have the honor and
privilege of being here with Anthony
popliano no stranger to those of us in
the Bitcoin and blockchain space Anthony
thanks for being here yeah thanks so
much for having me super excited to be
here uh the energy is great lots of
people who are still excited about all
of this so well that's great to see yeah
well you've been on the news quite a bit
lately I've been seeing you on various
channels uh we've got a lot of work to
do and my thought is it's time to roll
up our sleeves it's time for the serious
people uh to do professional and serious
things we have no more room to goof
around so what are your thoughts from a
an influencer perspective a thought
leader perspective an investor how do we
move forward in the coming weeks from a
public trust yeah perspective I mean
it's uh there's not one single thing
right uh trust is kind of compounded
over years and years and years and years
um and what's a little crazy is we've
been doing the right things it's just
there's been a bunch of people who've
been doing stupid things as well and so
uh those people get kind of cleared out
free market dynamics take over bad
people who do bad things eventually get
you know kind of uncovered uh and they
get washed out but what I do think is
very interesting is the people who have
been doing the right thing uh they were
here before they're still here now
they'll be here in the future and so for
those people I think one is just like
don't get uh discouraged that you know
the people who are doing dumb things get
uh attention they get Capital they get
all these things but ultimately this is
not a Sprint it is very much a marathon
and so if you look at you know bitcoin's
history uh and kind of the broader
industry what's fascinating to me is
we're only 15 years into this eventually
we're going to be talking about 50 years
into this and so what are the companies
who are the people who are still going
to be here then that's really I think
we're like the true signal is
agreed 100 so in your role you get
pulled into a lot of regulatory and
policy conversations
that's what we specialize I don't know
why they're doing that
well we need it uh so so what is the
primary thing if you had five minutes
with ginsler or with the chair of you
know Ways and Means or or any of these
uh legislators or Regulators you get
five minutes what do you what do you
tell them
yeah I don't know if it's a five minute
conversation which is part of what makes
it hard right it's also not a 280
character like Twitter uh conversation
either which uh the Nuance gets lost
um but I really think that uh there's
two core like arguments or talking
points that I try to hammer home the
first is this technology is as about
American As It Gets In terms of the
ability to have free markets the ability
to uh really Embrace capitalism the
ability to allow people to pursue the
American dream uh it returns a bunch of
Rights and and kind of individual
liberties back to Citizens themselves
um and it's done in a way where uh it's
very hard for people to uh kind of uh
corrupt it or to get too much control
too much power too much economic uh
might and so I think that's the first
thing it's just like this is an American
Technology from an ethos standpoint and
then the second thing is it is one of
the fastest growing economic sectors in
the world you can look at both the
economic value that's uh created and
captured you can look at job creation
you can look at uh kind of the
investment portfolios like all these
different components and so if you want
America to continue to be a leader both
from a capital Market standpoint but
also an impact on the citizens then you
have to embrace this and so if you can
combine the ethos of kind of American
society democracy and capitalism uh with
the potential impact that it can have to
the actual wallets of American citizens
hey we got to get this right now where
there's a lot of debate is what is right
right what are the rules how should we
enforce them who should be in charge all
that stuff is Up For Debate but I think
just getting people to understand this
is important and we got to get it right
uh that is actually a big leap forward
from where we were two or three years
ago we're getting there now let's get
forward and let's kind of figure out
what those rules should be
yeah and you mentioned job creation tax
revenue one of the things that we've
been working on studying in Texas is
what can we show to policy makers and
say hey not only are we doing the we're
developing this level of innovation
that's bringing businesses here but
let's talk about job creation locally
especially in rural areas so we've done
some studies 2 000 direct jobs for
Bitcoin mining in the state of Texas 20
000 indirect so 2000 W2 20 000 either
1099 or indirect jobs which is a
substantial number Bitcoin miners
utilize about 1.5 percent of the Texas
power grid so we're talking you know 16
1700 megawatts of power in Texas well
and when you think of that type of job
creation right I think people say to
themselves like okay that's like what
you're able to measure to your point
right it's probably even bigger than
that secondary effect and I also think a
lot about uh the compounding effect and
what you're going to end up getting and
I think what Silicon Valley really
benefited from was uh if you go back and
you study the history of Silicon Valley
there was a couple of people who said
hey we want to invest in these companies
these companies are going to go and
they're going to create a bunch of
economic value then the people who help
to build these companies who weren't the
founder are going to say this was fun I
want to go do it for myself they spin
out they go start more companies there's
Capital that gets recycled and you start
to compound now if you fast forward from
you know the 1950s and 60s to today
we're like holy [__] there's a TR you
know multi-trillion dollar industry this
is amazing look at all the jobs that
were created look at all the companies
that were created that's going to happen
in Texas around Mining and these
Technologies but it's also going to
happen around America and so I think
that we have to be careful that we don't
just simply allow people to take a
snapshot in like a static point in time
and say oh this is as big as the
industry is going to get because I think
that it's actually no we're at the kind
of the base of what ends up being this
like exponential growth and that's
really what gets exciting because you
have to allow for time to pass but if we
get the rules right today you lay the
groundwork and eventually that will
really Thrive here both in Texas and in
America
agreed so I want to Pivot us a little
bit to something a little more
controversial
um we we've got a lot of people on
Twitter on crypto Twitter that that
they're a little dogmatic in their
approach and understatement of the year
[Laughter]
with so many people coming into the
space and uh being exposed to the
culture on Twitter one of my concerns
and I wonder if you share this concern
is we we see sort of this and rightly so
Bitcoin is different it is uh something
that is apples and oranges and we should
kind of protect uh from a reputational
standpoint we shouldn't ever lump it in
uh and and I think as far as our
industry Association goes that's really
mostly what we talk about but we do it
in a very
um hopefully tactful way there's there's
been some activity on Twitter that's not
as tactful and I wonder I wonder what
your thoughts are like to me it's
concerning but I don't uh you know I
have I know a lot of these people that
are doing it I know them well they're
High character people they're high
conviction people so I very much respect
them but I do have a little bit of
concern that we're we're throwing the
big be out with the bathwater my biggest
thing is like Twitter's not real life uh
and we get to kind of remind people of
that uh yes it is where a conversation
happens it's not the full conversation
it's not the only conversation
um but it is a conversation an important
conversation and so uh there are going
to be people who are great communicators
they're going to be people who are
horrible communicators they're going to
be people who use uh Legacy
communication tactics and there's gonna
be people who use like the meme Lords of
the world and you know they're in this
new digital realm and they understand
how to communicate in uh kind of that
environment and so I always remind
myself that like we kind of need
everybody like we actually do need
people who can fire up a meme and go and
you know take on uh somebody who is uh
saying stupid things that's inaccurate
we also need somebody who can put on a
suit and tie and go to the White House
and say hey this is exactly how to think
about it in your terms in your world
right from your perspective
um and so what's unique about this is uh
there is no Central planning going on so
it's not like we have like hey let's
have a board uh you know board of
directors meeting and uh okay let's tone
down the you know the memes and let's
let's turn up the regulation talk right
or hey let's do vice versa it's every
person for themselves to some degree and
so of course you're going to get people
who do things that maybe everyone
doesn't agree with or whatever but what
I do think is very unique is that uh
Bitcoin has uh zero interest and doesn't
care what's going on on Twitter and so
if there's one thing that I kind of like
fall back on is like the Bitcoin network
is going to continue to produce blocks
of transactions regardless of the
conversation on Twitter is now to your
point we can be successful and shoot
ourselves in the foot or we can be
successful and like make it a little bit
easier for ourselves
um and so what I think has really
happened now is uh the people who have
certain communication tactics like
they're very self-aware of what they're
doing uh and we should actually embrace
that communication and we should use it
for what it is valuable for right uh I
don't think that people are gonna like
create memes
uh print them out on a piece of paper
and show up to like politician's office
and I hand them to them no it's very
much like for the digital realm it's
there to kind of combat all the fun and
all that type of stuff at the same time
what we need is we need tons of people
who say hey that's not my strength I
have these other strengths let me go and
do that and so I think about it less
about like hey let's tone down the
people on the Internet or tone down the
people who maybe you know have kind of
different tactics and instead let's
really ratchet up all the other
abilities that we have and if you can
get them onto equal footing that's
pretty much a beast you know in terms of
the ability for us to communicate
it's just it's a lot of work right that
that ends up being the uh the difficult
part I really like the way that you
articulated that and I think that's
that's a strategy you know with
um several influencers here in Austin
Texas Austin is the Bitcoin capital of
the world in my opinion and um we've got
some folks here who who do that really
well and to do that really tactfully and
so we're really appreciative of that and
I love what Austin is becoming and has
become you mentioned something I want to
draw attention to specialization as an
industry professionalizes people do
fewer things really broadly they do them
very deeply
um and so
kind of a honeycomb effect you've got
people that used to do three or four
different things and they just now they
specialize in their vertical
um what are some of the verticals that
you think the industry does really well
and where are some of the verticals that
you you think we need more people that
do this really well yeah um I think the
first thing that jumps to mind is just
uh we're really good at building uh
infrastructure obviously you know I
think uh Bitcoin uh as a payment Network
itself like the software of Bitcoin the
design of Bitcoin is the single greatest
invention In Our Lifetime there's a lot
of other things that people have done
that are amazing but I think that when
you really sit down and you understand
just what Bitcoin has been able to
accomplish uh it's breathtaking and in
order for Bitcoin to have reached the
amount of success that it has uh you
need to build all the infrastructure you
have to get the mining Network out there
all that stuff so that's great then if
you turn and you look and you say okay
what are the things that maybe we need
to get better at one of the biggest
things is the design the user experience
right the interfaces of this stuff
um if you go back and you look at you
know website from the mid-1990s we all
laugh now and there's like Nostalgia and
we're like oh my God like how did we use
that right you remember the AOL like
dial up sound and the little man running
across the screen and like all that
stuff and we're like that's crazy but
now here we are you know almost 30 years
later and like look at how amazing some
of these websites look and things like
that
I think Bitcoin and the broad industry
is going through the exact same thing
right uh and a very simple thing is just
like if your palm sweat and your heart
beats fast when you've got to send
Bitcoin to someone we probably got to
fix that right because there's a lot of
people who they're just not going to do
it right and and so uh that's a dumb one
it's a simple thing um but I think
that's the type of stuff that as more
and more people come in who have
experience building consumer products
have experience with uh design usually
interfaces things like that it'll just
naturally improve but those are the
people who first discover some of these
Technologies and are like hey let me go
do it uh and so I think it's just like
get more people into the industry and
then let them do what they're best at
and uh the beauty of kind of these like
open source type communities is that
people show up they work on what they're
interested in next thing you know we've
got the best team in the world and we
didn't have to pay them we didn't have
to you know go do uh uh recruiting firms
they just showed up because they were
interested in the idea
what do we have to do to get you to move
to Austin I thought about moving to
Austin I think I've talked about this
before
um so when I was in New York uh there
was three places that uh I told my wife
I said uh Austin Miami and Puerto Rico
she immediately told me no Puerto Rico
and I was like why and she's like I
don't want to be on an island they'll
say okay fine uh and so we came to
Austin we went to Miami as well
um and uh I love both places uh because
see myself living in both of them
um I think Miami won out uh mainly just
because uh it was close to the water
right like it's just it's just uh
weather-wise
um I don't like the cold and uh
depending on when you come to Austin uh
it's usually pretty warm but uh but
there's still a little bit of winter and
so uh I think that I'm probably gonna
stay in Miami and then just come to
Austin quite a bit I've been here you
know multiple times in the last two
months
um and to your point I think there's a
lot of great things that are happening
here uh in Austin specifically uh but
also in the greater state of Texas and
and what's fascinating to me is
um you know if you start to kind of zoom
out just from like Bitcoin in crypto
industry you have Tesla you have a lot
of these different factories
manufacturing and and types of
businesses that have uh the people who
work there are also very interested in
things like Bitcoin and so you can see a
world where there might be some people
who on the weekends and nights are
working on bitcoin stuff and they're
working at let's say a Tesla Factory
well then vice versa maybe at some point
they're like hey you know what I've done
this for three four five six years now I
actually want to go work on this stuff
full time and so what you're really just
doing is you're attracting technical
people who really like to build things
and you put them together and even if
they're not working on it full time
naturally some of that intelligence that
Capital seeps into the industry which I
think is just a tailwind and makes a
place like Austin really special
you so Capital formation is is Shifting
away from California uh I was at a trade
dinner last night with a delegation from
Alberta the wealthiest province in
Canada and they had a minister there
several uh delegates there and when I
was given my remarks I said you know we
feel like Alberta is the Texas of Canada
and a couple of them kind of you know
chuckled but then I thought immediately
I was like I should reverse that I said
uh I said Texas is the Alberta of the
United States and they all they all much
more loved that I guess yes so what we
just what we decided is we'll trade
California to Canada and we'll take
Alberta in the U.S that's probably a
pretty good idea but but as we see that
that Capital flow come towards or at
least away from Silicon Valley and
towards either Austin uh Miami Denver
um
there's a there's companies that and
I'll even give a shout out to tremble
Venture partners because I see one of
our colleagues from there you know
they're here intentionally in Austin
they are uh a you know Venture Capital
company they're funding
Bitcoin companies on lightning on you
know doing a variety of different things
mostly on uh less Mining and more kind
of on the layer two on lightning and
other things
um how do we
professionalize well let me ask it this
way how do we attract more of that
institutional Capital to some
non-traditional places like us Austin's
almost becoming traditional but it's
still
quasi-non-traditional do you see a
movement of non of uh institutional
Capital moving away from New York and uh
Silicon Valley I don't think location
matters anymore I think that's probably
like the biggest breakthrough is just uh
whether an investor still lives in
California New York or anywhere else in
the world
um they're not saying I only want to
invest in my backyard like that's the
real kind of zero to one
um you know kind of advancement
um and so what that does is you can be
an entrepreneur live anywhere in the
world go to the company they'll find you
and I think we've seen example after
example now of course there's still
concentration to kind of to your point
um and so what ultimately this does is
it opens up the kind of aperture for uh
investors it also now allows for much
bigger Capital Pools to look at your
business but it really still goes back
to the same thing if you just build a
great company people will be interested
people want to give you money right
that's their job is to find you and to
give you the money